zwölf jahre das ist so knapp unter der
höchststrafe von 15 jahren die die
staatsanwaltschaft gefordert hat davon
soll eine signalwirkung ausgehen sagte
das gericht wirkt so was tatsächlich
also schreckt so ein hohes strafmaß
potenzielle täter ab tja das ist eine
frage die ich ehrlicherweise so auch gar
nicht beantworten kann weil dazu fehlen
uns in der tat die studien wie
abschreckend auch gerichtsurteile wirken
können gerade im bereich von
sexualstraftätern jetzt gerade auch im
bereich gegen kinder
was sicherlich anders ist als in vielen
anderen fällen sie müssen sich immer
vorstellen dass der in anführungszeichen
normale sexuelle missbrauch gegen kinder
im strafrecht nur als vergehen gilt dh
wir haben zum beispiel einbruchdiebstahl
delikte die mit einem höheren strafmaß
bestraft werden und hier hat in der tat
das gericht direkt auf schweren
sexuellen missbrauch na ja auch darauf
abgezielt und insofern konnten hier auch
andere mittel ausgeschöpft werden und
dass das auch passiert ist mit
anschließender sicherungsverwahrung ich
glaube das ist etwas was für viele sehr
sehr zufrieden stellt aber auch
natürlich absolut angemessen ist über
dieses problem mit der justiz sprechen
wir nachher nochmal aber bevor wir
tiefer ins thema einsteigen möchten wir
uns machen wir den pfeil lichte genauer
angucken und auch den prozess heute und
den hat peter böhme für uns
zusammengefasst
seine opfer konnten sich nicht
verstecken er versteckte sich bis zum
schluss der 56 jährige andreas bauer
sein mittäter mario s zeigte sich
dagegen offen ihre geständnisse
ersparten den opfern immerhin die
quälenden aussagen vor gericht
gesprächen über einen tatzeitraum von 20
jahren in dem die angeklagten
unauffällig gewesen sind wo ihre taten
nicht aufgefallen sind und eben über
opfer
je nach zählweise 30 34 teilweise
kursierten auch die zahl von 41 opfern
das macht es natürlich schon besonders
die richterin sagte worte wie
abscheulich monströs widerwärtig
reichten nicht aus um den
kindesmissbrauch zu beschreiben andreas
v hatte laut gericht in über 200 mario
es in fast 50 fällen die kinder manche
erst vier jahre alt vergewaltigt die
folgen bleiben ein leben lang
opferanwälte das mädchen hat
schlafstörungen kann nicht einschlafen
im dunkeln verletzt sich selber es hat
aber auch zur folge gab leider dass ein
land durch das verhalten dass er dort
gelernt hat dass er das weitergeben hat
dass das als normal empfunden wurde
und so selbst zum täter wurde die taten
geschahen auf diesem campingplatz in
elbrinxen einem dorf bei löste andreas v
alleinstehend arbeitslos wurde hier auf
einer heruntergekommenen parzelle
er galt als vertrauenswürdig ihm wurde
2016 sogar ein pflegekind in obhut
gegeben dass er dann systematisch
missbrauchte ein system von laut gericht
einschüchterung verlockung und drohung
sorgte dafür dass die taten unbemerkt
blieben für den missbrauchsbeauftragten
der bundesregierung wird das thema nach
wie vor unterschätzt in der politik
herrsche immer noch geradezu
ahnungslosigkeit sagt er und präsentiert
erschreckende zahlen aus der so
genannten dunkelfeld forschung
wenn man diese zahlen der dunkel
feldforschung hochrechnet ist es
tatsächlich so dass wir davon ausgehen
müssen dass statistisch in jeder
schulklasse ein bis zwei mädchen und
jungen sind die von sexueller gewalt
aktuell betroffen sind oder betroffen
waren
röhrig fordert an den schutz plan für
jede schule denn dort könnte man wegen
der schulpflicht jedes betroffene kind
erreichen es geht darum dass
beschwerdemöglichkeiten für mädchen und
jungen geschafft werden dass ein
handlungsplan formuliert wird wenn
vermutung und verdacht im raum steht
wichtig ist das vertrauensvolle
ansprechpersonen benannt werden schule
als frühwarnsystem um missbrauch früh zu
erkennen zu beenden und damit fälle wie
in lüfte unwahrscheinlicher zu machen
ja und wie genau das passieren kann was
man da tun muss was da noch zu wenig
getan wird das diskutiere ich heute mit
professor kathinka beckmann sie ist
professorin an der hochschule koblenz
für pädagogik der frühen kindheit kennt
sich in diesem feld ganz gut aus dieser
fall möchte der ist ja doch in seiner
dimension erschreckend müssen wir davon
ausgehen dass es davon noch viel mehr
gibt und das unentdeckt bleibt oder ist
er doch in seiner dimension einzigartig
ja ich glaube dass es dann jetzt direkt
der unterschied zwischen ihnen und mir
weil mich hat das überhaupt nicht
überrascht er schreckt natürlich
erschreckend ist dass immer aber wir
haben also immer gerade auch heinrich
gehört er hat von dunkelfeld gesprochen
was wir auch jährlich absehen können ist
das hellfeld und wir haben hier
umgerechnet jeden tag 40 kinder sexuelle
gewalt angezeigt wird also jeden tag 40
das waren also im vergangen jahr mehr
als 14.000 und nur das ist nur das
hellfeld und wenn man sich das noch mal
vor augen führt dann brauchen wir
definitiv eine andere haltung nicht nur
in der sozialen arbeit sondern in der
gesamten gesellschaft und natürlich auch
in der politik dass hier wirklich
dringender handlungsbedarf besteht und
in meinen augen auch schon am besten in
der kita weil wir haben natürlich und
das zeitlich der ja auch sehr deutlich
ja nicht nur opfer im schulkind alter
sondern natürlich auch schon im kita
alter und auch noch davor also wir haben
auch babys die durchaus auch opfer von
übergriffen werden
woran liegt denn dass das in der
gesellschaft wie sie das sagen diese
haltung so ja noch nichts da zu sein
scheint wie sie das jetzt sagen wie das
auch der missbrauchsbeauftragte der
bundesregierung gesagt hat ja also meine
idee dazu ist das wenn man sich das
wirklich vor augen führt also jeden tag
40 wir haben nebenbei noch mal auch
andere gewalt bereiche die ja physische
misshandlungen und auch
versorgungsdefizite hier sterben
wöchentlich drei kinder in deutschland
also drei tote kinder in deutschland und
40 namen mit sexueller gewalt ich glaube
wenn man sich das wirklich in dieser
dramatik einmal an sich heranlässt das
erträgt man kaum und
ich glaube wir führen viele debatten die
er so emotional stellvertretend sind
noch und das ist einfach ja schwer
auszuhalten in dieser dimension
wie sehr nervt es sie denn als jemand
der sich damit täglich beschäftigt dass
man im grunde oder wie im grunde immer
nur darüber sprechen da müssen wir jetzt
auch ein bisschen selbst kritisch sein
wenn es solche großen fälle und solche
großen urteile gibt ja das ist etwas in
der tat da rennen sie bei mir offene
türen einen das ist traurig dass es
immer diese als einzelfälle deklarierten
dramen braucht damit die öffentlichkeit
aber auch die politik bereit es damals
punktuell hin zu gucken umgekehrt jetzt
aus fachlicher perspektive haben wir
durchaus ja auch andere ganz dramatisch
und traurige einzelfälle gehabt die in
der tat doch auch zu gesetzes
veränderungen geführt haben oder auch
die fachdebatte wirklich nach vorne
gebracht haben und das ist in der tat
die hoffnung die sich jetzt aus diesem
sehr sehr traurigen ja eben nicht
einzelfall aber eben aus dem so
genannten fall löste jetzt auch für mich
ergibt wenn ihr fragen oder kommentare
dazu hat an frau professor beckmann dann
ganz gerne in die kommentare schreiben
gerade habe ich da noch nicht so richtig
was gefunden aber das macht nichts wir
haben wir noch ein bisschen was vor uns
was im fall möchte ja eine besondere
konstellation war ist dass der
56-jährige dauercamper auch noch ein
pflegevater war und ein mädchen bei sich
hatte dass er auch als als lockvogel
quasi mit eingesetzt hat und das ist ja
schon verwunderlich weil eigentlich gibt
es für pflegeeltern ziemlich hohe hürden
bis die so ein kind bei sich aufnehmen
dürfen und sie auch ein spieß hat uns
mal zusammengefasst was da eigentlich
alles vorher passieren muss bis man ein
kind bei sich zu hause haben darf
etwa 81.000 kinder und jugendliche sind
nach den neuesten zahlen in
pflegefamilien untergebracht
das heißt 1 von 200 kindern in
deutschland
wer sich als pflegefamilie bewirbt wird
zunächst ausführlich durchgecheckt in
frage kommen paare genauso
alleinerziehende im führungszeugnis
sollte nichts auf gewalttätigkeit oder
gar misshandlungen hinweisen auch ein
gesundheitsattest ist pflicht die
persönlichkeit muss stabil genug sein
passenden beruf und dienstzeiten zu
einem guten familiären tagesablauf
genauso müssen die finanziellen
möglichkeiten und die wohnverhältnisse
offengelegt werden
wird das kind einen eigenen bereich ein
eigenes zimmer haben kommt die familie
bisher mit ihrem geld gut über die
runden
die pflege eltern bekommen finanzielle
unterstützung die aber nur für das kind
bestimmt ist
7 bis 800 euro pro monat dazu gut 200
euro kindergeld mit dem kindesalter
steigt auch die grund unterstützung
und je nach den problemen des kindes
gibt es weitere sonderzahlungen für
therapien oder anschaffungen
das jugendamt soll über die jahre
präsent bleiben unterstützen
kontrollieren notfalls einschreiten
eins ist klar hier geht es nicht um eine
adoption das pflegekind bleibt rechtlich
das kind seiner leiblichen eltern mit
denen auch regelmäßige treffen
stattfinden sollen wenn es dem kind
nicht schadet erst nach einer langen
gemeinsamen zeit können pflegeeltern
beantragen dass ihr pflegekind ganz bei
ihnen bleiben soll ja eigentlich sehr
hohe hürden und trotzdem ist es diesen
46 jährigen gelungen ein mädchen bei
sich aufzunehmen
dass er dann auch missbraucht hat und
als lockvogel einsetzen konnte
wie kann das sein dass diskutiere ich
heute mit professor kathinka beckmann
von der hochschule koblenz die ist
professorin für pädagogik der frühen
kindheit und sie haben ja auch in einem
jugendamt und verschiedenen
institutionen gearbeitet
da ist ja viel schiefgelaufen offenbar
vor ort in den jugendämtern
wie oft ist ihnen denn sowas aufgefallen
oder was ist ihnen aufgefallen in den
jugendämtern die können sie sich das
erklären dass so etwas passieren kann
na ja also ich sag mal an der stelle ist
wirklich genau dieses ganz große
fragezeichen wie konnte das wirklich so
entschieden werden das obwohl es
vermerke ja auch in der aktie gab es gab
ja hinweise von diversen anderen
akteuren wirklich verdachts äußerungen
die direkt in diese richtung wirklich
ist dieser mann möglicherweise pädophil
gibt es hier
sexuelle übergriffe das war durchaus
auch vermerkt und dann dort ein pflege
verhältnis zu installieren das ist
einfach wirklich ein ganz großes
fragezeichen was da sicherlich nicht nur
für mich bleibt und davon ab ein pflege
verhältnis auf einem dauer campingplatz
einzurichten sie haben es ja gerade auch
in ihrem film sehr schön gezeigt
das ist eigentlich nichts wo man denkt
dass da ein kind wirklich gut dauerhaft
aufgehoben ist also da gibt es sehr sehr
viele fragezeichen
es ist sicherlich für mich eher der
punkt
oder da werden jetzt auch andere
natürlich nachhaken wie konnte diese
entscheidung so getroffen werden gab es
eigentlich jemals eine richtige
risikoeinschätzung nur nachdem es diese
meldungen von außerhalb gab und wie ist
diese risikoeinschätzung wenn es sie
denn dann gegeben hat überhaupt
abgelaufen und also an der stelle denke
ich würde man auch noch mal sehr sehr
gut drauf schauen sie haben ja auch
untersucht wie jugendämter in
deutschland aufgestellt sind was ist
dabei herausgekommen und was haben sie
auch in ihrer arbeit damals im jugendamt
selber festgestellt wie sind diese
jugendämter auch personell aufgestellt
ja also personell da kann ich direkt
noch eine zahl nennen die der deutsche
beamtenbund auch letztes jahr schon in
der tat in die presse gemeldet hatte
weil es fehlen mindestens 3000 stellen
in den jugendämtern wir haben um die 560
in deutschland und wir haben umgekehrt
also auch steigende fallzahlen das heißt
wir haben nicht nur wenig aufstockung an
personal sondern wir haben quasi ein
gleiches level aber bei steigenden
fallzahlen und das kann natürlich auch
dazu führen dass ich bestimmte
hausbesuche nicht mehr machen
wir haben aber auch zum beispiel sehr
schwankende fallzahl belastungen das
heißt man kann eigentlich nicht über das
jugend ansprechen sondern wir müssen
über mehr als 500 sehr verschieden
ausgestattete jugendämter sprechen was
ihnen allen gemein ist ist ihr auftrag
zum kinderschutz und da muss man sagen
ist dass er auch ein appell an die
hochschulen weil die meisten denken dass
das jetzt die absoluten profis sind die
ja hier im kinderschutz angelegenheiten
auch arbeiten aber im studium der
sozialen arbeit ist kinderschutz kein
pflicht modul das heißt wir haben auch
ja ich sag mal pädagogische fachkräfte
die sicherlich in vielerlei hinsicht gut
arbeiten aber eben nicht dafür
ausgebildet worden sind alarmsignale von
kindern von auch kleinen kindern zu
erkennen oder eben auch mittäter
strategien vertraut sind und wenn ich
das nicht gelernt habe darauf also eine
darauf
zu achten dann über sehe ich eben auch
was und da denke ich gilt das jetzt auch
noch mal sehr sehr gut nicht nur eben
jetzt für die beteiligten jugendämter
hier in diesem campingplatz fall drauf
zu schauen sondern darf auch wirklich in
der fläche noch mal in frage zu stellen
ob wir hier nicht auch mehr verändern
müssen aber wie schnell kann das gehen
ich meine wenn sie jetzt sagen da
herrscht halt dich an einen
institutionellen mangel dass leute die
in die jugendämter gehen gar nicht
unbedingt dafür ausgebildet sind dazu
arbeiten was sie da tun sollen
das dauert jahre bis wir das aufgeholt
haben oder also das ist natürlich jetzt
ein
ja ja so eine herausforderung auf
mehreren ebenen was die hochschulen
konkret tun können also man kann ja
ständig auch ein lehrplan
ich sag mal thematisch aktualisieren
genauso wie man das thema
digitalisierung überall auch in die
studiengänge jetzt eingespeist hat
könnte man natürlich auch sehr schnell
in den studiengängen zur sozialen arbeit
aber natürlich auch pädagogik der frühen
kindheit wo wirklich erzieherinnen jetzt
akademie siert werden das als
pflichtbestandteil im studium
aufzunehmen
ehrlicherweise das ging relativ schnell
und sie können natürlich auch die schon
in den nazi wir reden hier über rund
14.000 mitarbeitenden in den sogenannten
asd es das ist die abteilung im
jugendamt die für den kinderschutz
zuständig ist und man kann hier
natürlich auch weiterbildung fortbildung
fachtage et cetera veranstalten dass man
die jetzt quasi auch in der fläche nach
qualifiziert aber natürlich das passiert
nicht von heute auf morgen aber ich
glaube das ist diese traurige chance die
jetzt hier wirklich drin liegt zu
erkennen da müssen wir ran und das auf
vielerlei ebenen haben denn die
jugendämter tatsächlich auch die
handhabe die sie brauchen wenn sie
erkannt haben dass es ein problem gibt
um die kinder schnell zu schützen
oder haben die eltern da doch immer noch
relativ viel einfluss möglichkeiten um
zu sagen nein ich möchte das nicht
also wir haben im jahr 2012 jahr das
bundeskinderschutzgesetz bekommen und
der auftrag der jugendämter ist ganz
klar geregelt aber auch zum beispiel der
freien träger also eine kitas etc
in dem moment wo ein kind sehr auffällig
wird und eben ich sag mal wenn sie
akteure haben die lehrer die
erzieherinnen die das dann auch noch
ihre befürchtungen an das jugendamt
melden dann muss das ist gesetzlich
vorgeschrieben das jugendamt sich dieses
kind anschauen auch vor ort persönlich
muss in den kontakt gehen mit den
sorgeberechtigten und daneben auch eine
einschätzung also eine sogenannte
risikoeinschätzung vornehmen und das ist
ganz klar geregelt was aber nicht
geregelt ist wie genau diese
risikoeinschätzung also welchen bogen
man benutzen muss das ist jetzt wiederum
sehr unterschiedlich in der hand habe
und das ist zum beispiel etwas wo ich
auch denke da könnten wir sehr viel
besser werden die also es ist alles
nicht legalisiert verstehe ist hier
richtig
genau das ist nicht standardisiert also
ich sag mal die gesetzlichen abläufe
also ich muss hingehen ich mache ein
hausbesuch ich gucke mir das kind vor
ort an
ich gehe ins gespräch mit den
sorgeberechtigten und wenn die
kooperieren hervorragend dann biete ich
hilfen an also eine
erziehungsberatungsstelle oder auch eine
ambulante massnahme dass zum beispiel
eine sozialarbeiterin auch jeden zweiten
tag von mir aus vorbei kommt aber auch
in familien wo es den verdacht gibt dass
der kinder missbraucht werden
ja also ich sag mal sie müssen daher
auch erst einmal ruhe bewahren und sich
das auch vor ort angucken und auch ich
sag mal einer dass es dieser schmale
grat zwischen nicht hysterisch werden
weil wir haben natürlich auch fälle
das zeigt die statistik niveau kinder
also wo verfahren eingeleitet werden und
wo jeder dritte fall dann so endet das
der verdacht unbegründet war und ich sag
mal ein kind einfach so aus einer
familie herauszuholen das geht auch
nicht
also da muss es wirklich schon sehr sehr
eindeutige hinweise zu geben und
deswegen haben wir auch profis also auch
die jugendämter können sich ja an andere
stellen wenden an die insoweit erfahrene
kinderschutzfachkraft oder an der
kinderschutzambulanz um sich hier auch
nochmal ich sag mal support zu holen um
ja auch noch mal für sich zu gesprächen
und natürlich auch im team also
reagieren wir hier jetzt über oder ist
das angemessen oder ist es schon so
dramatisch dass jetzt raus nehmen müssen
und im bereich sexuelle gewalt ist es
sehr viel schwieriger zu erkennen also
ich sag mal wenn sie eine klassische
physische misshandlung haben dann haben
sie eine blutende wunden sie haben
ausgeschlagene zähne eingerissene lippen
bändchen nur also massive
verletzungsspuren da ist es relativ
einfach
ja ich sag mal dann auch so eine
entscheidung zu treffen
genau weil man es sehen kann und im
bereich sexueller gewalt brauchen sie
ausgesprochen wirklich ein gutes wissen
um auch versteckte alarmsignale von
kindern lesen zu können also so
unterschiedlich jedes kind ist desto
unterschiedlich oder so unterschiedlich
sind auch die signale die dieses kind
aus sendet also können sie da mal
angefangen und die rampe schildern also
was sie da erlebt haben und woher man
macht am wasser kennt tatsächlich oder
woran sie das erkannt haben
ja also wie gesagt das ist also ich
kenne über 200 kinder mit denen ich
wirklich auch persönlich gearbeitet habe
insofern das würde ich ihnen jetzt hier
nicht zumuten aber ich sag mal sie haben
das immer so auf zwei ganz großen ebenen
wir haben kinder die einfach irgendwann
nicht mehr sprechen zum beispiel also
die sind vielleicht 45 jahre alt und die
konnten schon gut sprechen und dann
fallen die erst mal gerade in der kita
ganz lange gar nicht auf weil die sind
so bequem ja die übersieht man sehr
schnell weil die sitzen vielleicht still
in der ecke puzzeln für sich und konnten
mal sprechen und tun es einfach nicht
mehr
das sind die sehr sehr schwierig zu
erkennenden fälle weil die übersieht man
so weil die sind so einfach im umgang
anders haben wir dann das sind immer die
kinder ich sag mal die er so noch die
hoffnung haben endlich hilft mir mal
jemand hoffentlich sieht mich jemand und
das sind die lauten lärmenden aus
agierenden das sind zb kinder die viel
schlagen beißen spucken treten und die
fallen auf aber das war aber noch
vielleicht ihr schwer erziehbar oder
nicht richtig erzogen genau und das ist
jetzt genau auf die gratwanderung bei
natürlich nicht jedes spuckende beißende
laut aggressiv
aus agierende kind ist jetzt direkt ein
gewalt geschädigt das kind im sinne der
sexuellen übergriffe deswegen meinte ich
gerade eine der grat zwischen hysterie
und wegsehen ist sehr schmal
ich muss ab da wo ich ein sehr ungutes
gefühl als fachkraft habe einfach mir
auch die zeit nehmen und natürlich auch
wissen worauf muss ich noch achten also
ist das nur mal oder zieht sich das
durch ist das also eine verhaltensweise
die über wochen monate auch geht weil
das zeigte auch und das ist in der tat
traurige realität die meisten sexuellen
übergriffe ereigneten sich über lange
zeiträume und jedes kind bringt das nach
außen also viele spielen auch ganz
merkwürdige rollenspiele wo
sexualisierte ja genau wo auch das
sprachlich begleitet wird und ich sag
mal wenn sie erst mal so ein 56 jähriges
kind erlebt haben was dann so du dreimal
durch den arsch [ __ ] hohen tochter
oder so was sagt das ist so wo man denkt
okay und darüber muss man stolpern und
wir haben natürlich viele fachkräfte
noch mal in der kita eine ganz große
chance also dass auch schon wirklich
früh zu erkennen
die dann auch irritiert sind und denke
da habe ich mich doch bestimmt verhört
und da muss man dranbleiben und wenn
sich noch weitere verhaltensweisen dazu
ergeben
na ja ich sag mal dann vielleicht auch
bissspuren an den oberschenkel
innenseiten der gleichen wir haben
natürlich auch körperliche symptome im
bereich sexueller gewalt aber ich sag
mal in der schule sehe ich die auch als
lehrer nicht mehr weil ich sehe diese
kinder ja nicht mehr also ein bisschen
verloren weil sie sich nicht mehr um
wahrscheinlich im sportunterricht weil
sie sich schämen so wir haben jetzt
endlich auch mal ein paar kommentare wir
sind ein bisschen hier auf youtube
werden wir zugestimmt
aber ein paar haben wir gefunden hier
einmal die frage von jens ob es ein
netzwerk hinter diesen taten gibt also
ist es tatsächlich so wie man das jetzt
denkt es ist ein netzwerk von von
menschen die sich zusammengeschlossen
haben um kinder zu missbrauchen ist das
eher der fall oder sind die einzeltäter
in der mehrheit
also wir haben beides wir haben einen
ganz großen bereich von organisierter
kriminalität der sich vor allem auch im
bereich von kinderpornografie ereignet
weil hier muss man einfach ganz klar
sagen es wird so unglaublich viel geld
mit kinderpornos und auch mit dem
verkauf von kindern also von nicht nur
von pornos ohne von kindern wirklich
verdient das ist natürlich ein delikt
bereich der jetzt auch vom bka ganz klar
ganz anders angeguckt wird wir haben
aber auch ich sage mal den ganz
klassischen ich sag mal analogen
missbrauch der meistens wirklich im
häuslichen umfeld sich ereignet aber
bitte bitte man muss immer bedenken es
müssen nicht immer die ich sag mal die
väter oder die neuen partner sein
wir haben auch viele weibliche schädige
rinnen und wir haben natürlich auch zb
geschwisterkinder die übergriffig sind
ja also das ist nicht also wir haben
nicht den einen täter
das ist sehr sehr unterschiedlich jetzt
lassen sie uns zum abschluss noch mal
kurz auf die frage nach der justiz
gucken sie haben gerade schon am anfang
des gesprächs angedeutet dass
kindesmissbrauch nicht als müssen sie
mich unterstützen im justiziablen
bereich schwerwiegenden missbrauch haben
sie gesagt es ist nicht sondern das ist
quasi ein mittelschweres vergehen wenn
man unterscheidet schlicht und
ergreifend zwischen vergehen und
verbrechen und erst der sogenannte
schwere sexuelle missbrauch also wo es
um vergewaltigung zum beispiel geht ist
dann halt auch ein verbrechen wo man
dann eben auch hohe gefängnisstrafen
aussprechen kann was ja jetzt heute auch
passiert ist aber wir haben den
sogenannten sexuellen missbrauch also wo
das schwer als vokabel vorher fehlt und
dann sind wir eher im bereich des
vergehens und dann wundert man sich eben
und was ist ja auch schon passiert warum
so viele wirklich mit bewährungsstrafen
oder auch im strafmaß unternehmer jahr
zum beispiel rausgehen aus einer
verhandlung
herr röhrig das ist ja der unabhängige
missbrauchsbeauftragte der
bundesregierung hatten wir auch im
beitrag soeben der hat auch beklagt
jetzt im zuge dieser ganzen geschichte
dass die justiz und auch die
ermittlungsbehörden solche fälle nicht
ernst genug nehmen
was das erstmal eine vermutung auch
daran liegen könnte dass es eben nur als
vergehen gilt und nicht als verbrechen
er meint da müsste mehr passieren dann
müssten auch gesetze geändert werden ist
das tatsächlich so einfach zu tun
einfach hebel umlegen und dann erledigt
sich das vielleicht schneller von
alleine
naja dafür leben wir in einer demokratie
dass wir auch gesetze die schon da sind
auch noch mal ich sag mal verändern
können und ich bin da ganz beim herrn
röhrig ich sehe das ganz genauso ist es
höchste eisenbahn dass wir auch hier den
sogenannten sexuellen missbrauch und
eben ohne das schwer davor auch als
verbrechen deklarieren also ich sag mal
ist schon eine wirklich schwierig oder
schwer auszuhalten eine schieflage warum
einbruchdiebstahl schwerer gestraft wird
als eine sexuelle gewalt gegen kinder
zum abschluss noch mal eine frage auch
wenn sie wahrscheinlich schwer zu
beantworten das war ja schon deutlich
gemacht haben das ist alles nicht so
einfach zu erkennen ist aber jeder
einzelne was können wir tun um kindern
in so einer notsituation vielleicht
schneller zu helfen
ich glaube das erste was wir tun müssen
ist wirklich diese haltung zu entwickeln
dass gewalt gegen kinder tagtäglich in
deutschland sich ereignet und erst wenn
ich das wirklich zulasse in meiner
gedankenwelt neben den anderen themen
wie klimawandel etc dann bin ich glaube
ich auch in der lage vielleicht auf
diese kinder aufmerksam zu werden
ansonsten kann ich ganz viel wissen aber
wenn ich denke das passiert nur woanders
aber nicht in meinem idyllischen dorf
dann ja dann nützt das nichts frau
bergmann vielen dank für ihre
einschätzungen und für ihre expertise
2 kommentare möchte ich gerne noch
vorlesen zum schluss auf facebook von
peter kowalsky das schreibt potenziellen
tätern sollte bewusst sein ihre
neigungen sind krankhaft aber sie können
hilfe bekommen und sind gefordert sich
diese hilfen selbst zu holen da können
die medien über aufklärung nennung von
hilfe dreßen und so weiter viel leisten
das möchte ich hiermit noch mal
unterstreichen und darunter schreibt
dann conny richtig und die gesellschaft
darf nicht wegschauen nur weil es ein
schwer zu ertragen das thema ist hilfe
für menschen mit solchen eigenen muss
gefördert werden damit der zugang
möglich ist einfach ist
das wäre ja vielleicht auch noch eine
andere präventive maßnahme ich sage euch
vielen dank fürs zuschauen vielen dank
nochmal frau beckmann für ihre zeit und
wenn wir sehen uns wieder am nächsten
dienstag 20.30 an dieser stelle wo auch
immer ihr gerade im internet zugeguckt
habt wir freuen uns wenn er wieder dabei
sein und uns natürlich kommentare likes
jetzt in charsadda las was tut was er
tun könnte um uns zu pushen
ich sage aber für heute erstmals bis
bald so und wenn euch das streamen
gefallen hat dann geht es hier noch was
was wir vielleicht auch gefällt nämlich
zum beispiel dieser stream da haben wir
über gewalt in der familie gesprochen
und auch mit einer betroffenen geredet
oder hier unten in dem stream ging es um
hass in der gesellschaft und die frage
ob wir immer aggressiver miteinander
umgehen und natürlich wenn ihr keinen
livestream mehr verpassen wollt dann
einmal hier ein abo hinterlassen dann
kriegt hier alles mit was wir ins
internet stellen in dem sinne viel spaß
und vielen dank